just posted Our World Cup toy high tea  and I wanted to point out some of my  favorite little details that you might  have missed for starters erling Hollins  locked up in this toy package called the  eliminated collection he's one of the  best players in the world right now but  Norway didn't qualify so sorry early  then we get Neymar balancing his boot on  his head in reference to his legendary  Sally a few years ago we of course had  to throw on maradona's famous hand of  God incident where he handed the ball to  give Argentina the lead over England in  the 1986 World Cup quarterfinals the  English are still pissed about it  because well it was his hand and the men  still haven't won a major trophy since  1966